Do you guys know who Ariel Parson is?
>> I think it's my dermatologist.
>> Wait?
No.
>> No.
No idea.
No.
>> No one I know.
>> That's great,
do you know what this means?
This means that there is somebody out
there that is not either a direct
friend, family member,
or pet of someone in this room
that's using Shopping List++.
>> That's awesome.
>> I know, high fives all around,
high fives, high fives.
High fives, JP!
>> You seem a lot more energetic.
Yeah, I don't know if it's that red
black caffeinated insta I had or
the fact that I've finally been able to
get some sleep, but man, I feel great.
That's good to hear.
>> This is a real person.
>> I know a real person.
>> No, that's not what I meant.
This is a spambot or a malicious user.
>> Nah.
I mean, come on JP.
It's not like somebody's trying
to hack into our system.
>> Well, I hate to burst your bubble but
now the app is released,
aren't you at all
concerned about security?
>> Not now JP.
Tonight, we dance.
[MUSIC]
[SOUND]
[LAUGH]
[MUSIC]